Catherine Abreu: We know with certainty
that fossil fuels need to be phased out.
There's really no question
in the science at this point.
Tessa Khan: The arguments
for transitioning away from fossil fuels
at speed
have never been more compelling.
I think the responsibilities
of governments
to accelerate that transition
have never been so acute.
Laurence Tubiana:
It has to be quite radical.
It could have been done slowly.
But now we are running against time,
and the climate impacts are now
not for tomorrow.
It's for today.
Hisham Mundol: The role of fossil fuels
between now and 2050
is that of a necessary evil.
Hongqiao Liu: So we have a very
complicated relationship with fossil fuels
at the moment.
It's like your ex-partner,
you want to get rid of them,
but they stick around.
Rebekah Shirley: In Africa, for instance,
where I live, it's a bit more complicated.
Vijaya Ramachandran: I don't think
it's fair to poor countries
to say you have to be renewable only,
when the rich countries are doubling down
on oil, coal and gas.
HL: We need to debate.
We need we need that exchange.
We need to understand each other's views
and to start with the concept
of the dilemma that we’re facing.
Zoë Knight: In my mind, the biggest
obstacle is the speed of collaboration.
We speak at cross-purposes
with each other.
Mary Robinson: We've got to deal with this
much more quickly than we're doing.
How do we raise the temperature?
How do we increase the energy for action,
the passion for action,
the heartfelt need for action
which will move us?
[TED Countdown]
[Dilemma Series]
[How do we move from fossil fuels
to clean energy quickly and fairly?]
Lindsay Levin: We're standing at a crucial
crossroads in history.
We live in a world where our energy
system is overwhelmingly dependent
on burning fossil fuels.
What are the viable pathways
to a clean and safe future,
and how do we collectively
navigate this transition?
I'm Lindsay Levin,
co-founder of Countdown,
and this is the second installment
of our Dilemma Series.
We know that credible people,
including many of you,
disagree in some pretty fundamental
ways on this topic,
the core of the climate challenge.
Recently at the Barbican Centre in London,
we brought together experts,
activists and leading voices
in the climate space to speak,
listen and work together
as we figure out how to make progress
despite our differences.
While the need to get off fossil fuels
is straightforward and urgent,
the pathway to doing it equitably
is anything but.
Here's TED science curator David Biello
to frame the basic ideas
behind this dilemma.
David Biello: Today, more
than 80 percent of modern energy
comes from burning fossil fuels.
That means more
than 40 billion metric tons,
that's 40 gigatons, of CO2
gets dumped in the air each year.
And that number is growing.
At the same time,
hundreds of millions of people
live with limited or no access
to modern energy at all.
That means they have
contributed almost nothing
to the greenhouse gas pollution
causing the climate crisis.
So do we stop fossil fuel exploration
and production entirely?
Do we encourage it for certain
communities but not others?
And if so, where?
How do we actually get renewables to scale
and how do we pay for it all?
These questions are incredibly complex,
but the takeaway is clear.
We need to eliminate fossil fuels
and use what we must to ensure
that everyone benefits.
Let's start with some facts and figures
about where we are today.
Here's Adair Turner.
Adair Turner: The International Panel
on Climate Change estimated in 2018
that if we are to have
even a 50-percent chance
of limiting global warming
to 1.5 degrees centigrade,
we cannot emit more than 500 gigatons
of CO2 between 2020 and 2050.
But actually, we're two years
into that 30-year period.
We've been running
at 40 gigatons per year,
so we've only got 420 gigatons left.
That 420 gigatons would be emitted
if we burnt 70 billion tons of coal
plus 65 trillion cubic meters of gas
plus 350 billion barrels of oil.
But at the current rate we will have
burnt all of that in 12 years.
We have got to find a way of leaving
the vast majority of coal, oil and gas
in the ground,
even if it is in someone's interest
to dig it or drill it up.
So what should we do?
In one area, the answer is clear.
Renewable is now a cheaper way
to produce electricity than coal
in almost all countries of the world,
so we should build
no more coal electricity plants,
no more coal mines.
And we should not invest anything
in the extension of existing coal mines.
For gas and oil, it is a bit trickier.
International Energy Agency
suggests a distinction.
It says that we should invest
nothing in exploration for
or production from new oil and gas fields,
but that it’s OK to invest something
to maintain production
from existing fields.
But there are some people
who would challenge
the morality of that distinction,
because if there's an absolute limit
to how much gas we can safely burn,
it's not clear that squeezing
a little bit more out of the North Sea
is more acceptable
than developing a new gas field
in an African country
whose past cumulative per capita emissions
have been a tiny fraction of the UK's.
We now have the technologies
to dramatically reduce
the demand for fossil fuels,
and we should deploy them
as rapidly as possible.
That means ensuring that electricity
systems in every developed country
get to zero emissions by 2035
at the very latest
and ideally earlier, with no coal
and only a very, very small
role for unabated gas.
We should be aiming to reduce
coal demand 90 percent by 2050,
oil demand at least 75 percent
and gas demand by well over 50 percent.
And we are running out of time
to do it fast enough.
LL: Those are some big reduction targets,
and we need to meet them.
But as we move there,
we'll still be using some fossil fuels
to meet energy demands.
How do we do that while accelerating
our transition to renewables?
Some people think we can work
with the fossil fuel industry
and want to pressure it to do better.
Others propose more radical departures.
Here are a few opinions on this issue,
starting with Jérôme Schmitt,
a former oil industry executive
who is now a senior fellow
at the Columbia Center
on Sustainable Investment.
Jérôme Schmitt: I'm not aware of any
net-zero scenario compliant
with 1.5 degree or two degree
that does not involve even
a little bit of fossil fuel
by 2040 or 2050,
especially for the developing
part of the world.
Therefore, some people will need
to have an all-in understanding
of the energy system
and be able to manage
the complexity of producing
and supplying to customers
and to countries
clean energy on one side and less
and less fossil fuel on the other side
and concentrate the fossil fuel
supply and demand
on the absolute necessary means and usage
and increase progressively
the shift from one to the other.
Those who have the competency today
to manage this complexity
and the balance sheet
is still the oil and gas industry,
whether we like it or not.
So I would take the oil and gas industry
as an opportunity to go faster,
to make it right better
than we would do it without them.
But if it doesn't prove possible
because the oil and gas industry
doesn't shift and doesn't adapt,
we must do without.
Ramez Naam: Oil and gas companies
have to realize --
they don't always,
but they really should realize --
the writing is on the wall.
We're spending close
to twice as much on clean energy
as we are on fossil fuel
infrastructure already,
and that gap is just
going to widen and widen.
So I think if we can pivot
those companies, that industry,
into working on a clean future,
it's a good thing.
But we shouldn't have illusions
that it's going to happen by itself.
The pivot that has happened has been
because companies have seen
that the future is clean.
And so a combination
of continuing to push on policy,
on citizen advocacy
and on driving for the technologies
that disrupt fossil fuels
is what will cause those large,
entrenched fossil fuel companies
to pivot towards the clean future.
Tzeporah Berman: We're living the last
gasp of the fossil fuel industry,
and they're doing everything they can
to weaken climate policy
and hold on to the market
because they know renewables are cheaper.
MR: There was a great opportunity
to move with all the skills
that the fossil fuel industry
has built up over the years,
convert over to clean energy.
That would have been a wonderful moment.
If that had happened,
things would be very different.
We don’t have the time now to get into
a long, transition-y kind of discourse,
which is what most of them seem to want.
They lack the urgency
of now in their talk.
DB: As you can see,
there's a lot of skepticism
about the fossil fuel industry
based on its history of deception.
Here's well-known climate
activist Luisa Neubauer,
urging us not to believe
everything we hear.
Luisa Neubauer: People, for instance,
call the climate crisis manmade.
And while there were indeed
humans behind it,
it's much less manmade
and much more fossil-fuel-made.
It's made possible by the exploitation
of coal, oil and gas
and the profit-driven
economic systems behind it.
Calling the climate crisis manmade
implies it's an accident of human nature,
whereas it's actually
a relatively small group of people
and just a few places around the world:
the fossil fuel industries,
their marketing and their
political supporters.
The fossil fuel industry itself
is also a powerhouse of fairy tales.
Fifty years ago,
they knew that their business
would lead us into a climate disaster.
They denied their own climate science
that they did themselves,
and by that,
they stole our very first
historic chance to act from us.
So now, for many lives,
it's already too late.
And this time they present themselves
as part of the solution.
They call it transition.
They promise innovation,
they speak of green growth.
And it sounds wonderful.
It is powerful, too.
I would like to believe that, too.
But I cannot.
We do not have time for any more delay.
So whoever tells us that they will
just need some more time,
does not understand the very basic logic
of the crisis we are in.
Back in Hamburg, when I was in school,
we could get 90 minutes
to finish a math exam.
The fossil fuel industry is, in a way,
taking that very exam right now.
But instead of 90 minutes,
they tell us they will finish
in nine years.
Back in school,
that attitude would have gotten me
failing my assignments.
If fossil fuel industries don't listen
when people and science tell them
to get out of fossil fuels,
they should not be listened to
when they tell us more fairy tales
about wanting to be part of the solution.
If fossil fuel industries
get to make the rules
about the transition
we so desperately need,
we will not get that transition.
LL: The question
of whether there should be any
new expansion of fossil fuels
is hotly contested,
and there are passionate
points of view on both sides.
With a powerful perspective
on the injustice of banning fossil fuels
in developing countries,
here's economist Vijaya Ramachandran.
VR: The average Nigerian consumes
about 133 kilowatt hours
of electricity a year.
What the average American
consumes in four days.
In Nepal, that number
is 231 kilowatt hours.
In Haiti, it's only 37.
So what does all of this
mean for real people?
It means that they might have a few
lights at home or a small fan,
but no refrigerator, no water heater,
no safe cookstove.
It means that poor people stay poor.
Now let's look at climate change.
Poor people did not create
the carbon emissions
that have caused climate change.
The 64 poorest countries in the world
account for less than five percent
of annual carbon emissions.
Even India, often perceived
as a climate villain,
adds about seven percent.
Poor people are not to blame.
Germany's coal plants emit
four times more carbon
than Pakistan, Uzbekistan,
Lao and Bangladesh combined.
Yes, energy, poverty
and climate change are intertwined,
but not in the way most people think.
Most people think that poor countries
need to moderate their energy use
to address climate change.
The reality for poor people
in these countries
is that they need a lot more energy
to adapt to climate change.
As natural disasters get worse,
they will need more concrete and steel
to build resilient homes
and schools and roads.
As temperatures rise,
they'll need air conditioning
and cold storage for food and medicines.
As droughts become more common,
they'll need fertilizer,
pumped irrigation, desalination.
All of these responses to climate change
are going to require a lot more energy.
So the good news
is that we don't need to fear
this high-energy future for poor people.
All of this energy
that they will likely need
will come from low-carbon sources
to a great extent.
The abundance of wind, solar,
geothermal and hydropower
in Africa and Asia
means that a lot of the energy
that we are going to see
will not likely increase
carbon emissions very much.
So how can the US and Europe
be smarter about ending energy poverty
and addressing climate change?
First of all, this rich-world hypocrisy
of more fossil fuels for me,
but not for thee, must end.
Governments in poor countries must be able
to pursue a range of energy sources.
Renewables will likely
be the lion's share,
but there will be some
fossil fuels in the mix.
Natural gas, for example,
is abundant in Africa.
Natural gas has powered the energy
transition in the United States.
Natural gas can fuel power plants.
It is one of the best feedstocks
for producing fertilizer,
and it is one of the safer
and cleaner cooking fuels
for women in poor countries.
Renewables can be paired with natural gas
to increase the share
of low-carbon energy sources.
No country, not the US, not the UK,
not in Europe, not China,
has developed without fossil fuels.
The United States has recently passed
historically large investments
in clean energy,
but also in some fossil fuels,
taking a very practical approach
to its domestic energy transition.
The United States and other rich countries
should take that same practical approach
when it comes to funding
energy projects in poor countries.
Let's not impose unnecessary
and unjust restrictions
on those who are least responsible
for climate change.
LL: If the lion's share
of new energy production
in the developing world
will be renewables,
a lot of new financing
is going to be needed.
Here's Rebekah Shirley
of the World Resources Institute
on why that's not happening yet.
RS: Africa is perhaps the continent
that needs least convincing
about the clean energy opportunity
for health, livelihoods and economy.
As the fastest-growing, yet least
electrified continent on the globe,
most in need of power systems
that can help fortify
against the onslaught of climate shocks
with both abundant fossil
and renewable energy resources
to build them,
Africa's energy transitions
and how to dissuade
the use of fossil fuels
have become an intense
international debate.
Many sub-Saharan African countries
already rely on low-carbon resources.
Kenya, where I live,
generates 90 percent of its power
from renewables like geothermal
and hydropower.
Even in West Africa,
where renewable shares tend to be lower,
countries like Ghana generate
over a third of their power
from renewable energy resources.
And countries like Namibia
are at the forefront of innovation
on clean fuels like green hydrogen.
Couple all of that with housing
one of the world's largest carbon sinks,
the Congo Basin,
and sub-Saharan Africa
is consistently recognized
as pulling more than its fair share
of the global decarbonization effort.
So if the need is urgent
and if the resources are bountiful,
then why are we still so far away
from this clean-energy future for Africa?
And what I've learned is that though
the world loves to remind Africa
about its vast clean-energy potential,
the financial flows
to deliver that potential
remain troublingly scarce.
Projects and businesses incur a number
of hidden compounding costs and premiums.
Like the risk perception premium.
Or the "paying back your US dollar loan
in a constantly depreciating
local currency" premium.
Or the "expected to deliver
conventionally high rates of return
while raising your revenues from customers
that earn less than a dollar
a day" premium.
So international finance markets
are not appetized,
and financial flows here remain a trickle
despite a pipeline of ready projects.
In fact, though 17 percent
of the global population
and almost 90 percent of those
still without access to basic energy,
today Africa accounts
for a mere two percent
of global clean-energy finance.
From this perspective,
we can see a key missing ingredient:
international cooperation
to deliver the finance flows
that Africa sorely needs.
Because there’s so much potential
waiting right at the cusp.
If local enterprise had access
to long-term, low-cost financing,
like their counterparts
in other regions of the world
can simply take for granted,
then Africa's clean-energy future
would build itself.
HM: A lot of renewables
technology already exists.
The finance flows, especially to,
you know, lower-emission countries
don't exist.
These are the countries that need
to grow and growth needs energy.
That energy does not
have to come from fossil fuels.
CA: We often speak
with the acceptance of this tautology
that no country has ever developed
without the use of fossil fuels.
But that's not the whole truth, right?
The whole truth is
that no country has developed
without the use of fossil fuels yet.
LT: You have to really
invest in the future
of these low-income countries.
And access to energy,
really looking at the poorest
households in all the region
is really an important thing.
If not, the transition
will always appear very unfair.
MR: The World Bank
hasn't been doing enough
to provide that more concessional finance
that brings in private-sector financing
and that, you know,
really looks at what are the projects
that are ready for investment
and takes risks because it's really
important to have a sense
that Africa is part
of the clean energy going forward.
LL: Global finance isn't flowing at scale
where it's needed most.
How do we change that?
Here's Zoë Knight of the HSBC
Center for Sustainable Finance
to explain two major roles
that banks could play.
ZK: So the most immediate,
pressing task that we have
is to finance the transition, right?
And banks are mission-critical
to making that happen.
And the reason for that is because
we have two very powerful levers.
The first is really to take
environmental impact into account
in the financing decisions that we take,
and we're working on that.
And the second is to really
actively engage
with the governments that we finance,
the state-owned corporates
that we finance
and really work through how they can
deliver their transition plan.
So if we think about the next
10 to 15 years,
the industrial landscape is going to look
very different than it does from today,
particularly in the case of energy.
And we know that that's taking trillions
of investment to make the shift.
We need a trillion per year
by the end of the decade
to have half a semblance
of being on track for net zero.
And let me be clear,
one of the things that the financial
system absolutely has to do
is enable a science-aligned phase down
of the financing of fossil fuels.
We have to do that.
But equally,
we need to channel the capital
that is being generated
from the oil and gas industry
for good purpose
because we need the know-how of the sector
and we need to make capital move
in a way that's necessary.
So think about this.
The International Monetary Fund
has just estimated
that the Middle East oil and gas
companies will generate
an incremental 1.3 trillion [dollars]
in revenues over the next four years.
The banks and financiers can help move
that money into renewables
in a way that will make us achieve
the net-zero ambition much, much faster.
DB: In any discussion on this topic,
it's easy to get lost in the argument
or focus entirely on the end goal.
What's also critical
is that we need more planning
to get us off fossil fuels rapidly
and without major disruptions
that might undermine confidence
in the energy transition itself.
Here’s engineer and environmental
sociologist Emily Grubert.
EG: If we succeed at reaching
international climate goals,
the fossil fuel infrastructure systems
that support about 80 percent
of global energy consumption
will mostly, if not entirely, retire
over the next few decades.
What I'm talking about
is big infrastructure
like power plants and refineries,
but it's also things like
gas stations and people's cars,
stoves and furnaces.
Fossil fuel infrastructure
is a complex network
of high-hazard industries
that need to be able
to continue to operate safely
until the new system
is completely ready to take over,
including during emergencies
complicated by climate change.
Just letting these systems go away
would be deeply disruptive and hazardous.
We'd expect disproportionate
harm to overburdened
and underserved communities
who can't opt out
from skyrocketing prices,
abandoned remediation plans
and declining access to energy services.
This means ongoing fossil expenditures
and a reliance on highly-trained workers
in industries that might not
outlast their careers --
with a simultaneous focus on phasing out
these same industries
as quickly as possible
to address climate change
and a host of other
environmental injustices.
This is why we need to plan.
And right now, there's basically
nowhere in the world
where these urgently needed plans
for phasing out the fossil system
while phasing in the clean
energy system exist.
When we talk about climate goals,
the question I like to ask is:
If we actually believed
we were going to succeed,
what would we need to be doing right now?
One strategy here is to set deadlines
for fossil asset retirements.
Ample notice, say, a decade,
gives communities enough time
to create and implement plans,
and a legislated end date
gives people enough confidence
to commit to what can be
an intense process.
I showed that in the United States,
requiring all fossil fuel-fired power
generators to close by 2035,
which is President Biden's power sector
decarbonization target,
would actually allow
the large majority of them
to meet or exceed a typical lifespan,
potentially giving communities
some confidence
that these deadlines are manageable.
That is what earns
and maintains trust.
Not far-off emissions targets
with vague implementation plans.
The alternative of unplanned
transitions is unacceptable
but common.
Planning the transition is an ethical
responsibility that takes time
but also creates opportunities
to implement a just
and sustainable future
that corrects the harms of the past.
Collaboration and a laser-like focus
on ensuring people have what we need
to succeed through this transition
will be critical,
particularly as the transition collides
with climate tragedies.
What would we do now
if we believed we'd succeed?
Manish Bhardwaj: Emily Grubert
said something which I'm going to,
really sort of, take away,
maybe even teach:
that plans build trust.
Promises, you may not believe mine,
I might not believe yours,
but if we put something down,
this is what we are going to do
year after year,
then I think that can build trust.
I think that's just a beautiful thing
that I'm carrying away from her.
LL: Emily challenged us to act
like we're going to succeed.
Ramez Naam, a technologist
and entrepreneur,
believes we have a real shot at it.
Renewables are plummeting in price,
and there's opportunity to increase
their share around the world
if we get out of the way of progress.
Here's some of his talk.
RN: Clean energy will win
on cost definitively,
but only if we get out of the way
and allow it to be built.
Let's focus on that first point.
Let's look at the cost
of clean energy technology.
In 1975,
if you were buying a solar panel
per watt of power that it produced,
it would cost you 100 US dollars.
By 2020,
that cost had declined
to 20 cents per watt of power.
That's a 500-fold decline.
This is unlike anything else
ever seen in energy.
It is unlike anything else ever seen
in physical infrastructure.
And it continues today,
and it is likely to continue
for decades to come.
Now, this has surprised
the leading experts on clean energy
and even the biggest optimists
on the future of clean energy.
We've seen the cost of batteries
that power our electric vehicles
and grid energy storage
drop at the same pace or faster
than the pace of solar.
And we are just at the very beginning
of an exponential cost decline
in the cost of using clean electricity
to make hydrogen and other fuels
that we can use to power industry,
to provide weeks or months
of storage on the grid
and to provide fuels
we can use for aviation,
for shipping and so on.
Clean energy technologies
are technologies,
and they drop in cost like technology.
As they are scaled,
they come down in price.
Meanwhile, fossil fuels are commodities,
and fossil fuel prices
fluctuate over time.
But there's two barriers
I want to talk about in particular,
which are the reluctance to build --
not in my backyard --
and the challenges with permitting.
Because we look at renewables
and a common complaint is
they take up too much land.
All of us want clean energy
infrastructure,
but many of us don't want it
in our backyard.
In winter you have one-seventh
the solar resource in the UK
that you have in summer.
You have one-sixth the solar resource
in Germany that you have in summer.
So every model,
every simulation of weather
and energy demand shows this.
It shows that if you want to have
the highest reliability grid
at the lowest cost
with the least carbon emissions
and the most clean energy deployment,
you want to build a continent-sized grid.
In China, the bulk of energy demand
is on the East Coast,
yet the greatest solar resources
and wind resources are in the interior.
And China is building literally scores
of high-voltage power lines
that transmit power
from where the sun and wind are
to the coasts,
where the energy demand is.
And the longest of these lines right now,
that Ürümqi to Shanghai line,
is 3,400 kilometers long.
It is 90 percent efficient,
very low losses,
and it adds maybe a penny or two
to the cost of electricity.
That's what's technically feasible
with current technology,
let alone advances.
In Europe, that would allow us
to transmit electricity
from Seville to Copenhagen.
To bring power from the North Sea
to anywhere in the continent
that needs it.
In my home country, the United States,
we could bring power from the sunny,
wide open areas of New Mexico
to population and land-dense New York,
which doesn't get so much sun.
And we could take wind power
from the Great Plains,
that are largely devoid of population,
and bring it to the coasts in winter.
That is what a modern grid looks like.
And yet we are not building this.
It is time for us to build.
DB: With technology advancing
as fast as it is,
there’s certainly hope that we can
meet our energy transition goals,
and there are ways to ensure
that everyone benefits in this transition.
But it's going to be challenging.
LL: There's no shortage of ideas,
but time is running out,
making it all the more critical
to collaborate with urgency
and resolve this fundamental dilemma.
Here, again, are some leading voices
on how we get there.
MR: We all need to do three things.
We need to make the climate crisis
very personal in our lives,
change our habits a bit as a result.
Secondly, we need to get angry
about those who aren't doing enough.
And thirdly, we need to imagine
this world that is round the corner.
ZK: Every year I can see more focus
from different actors
that are needed
to be part of the solution.
LT: Renewable energy
is a good business in many places.
HM: There is a strong
business case for it.
It makes investment sense.
HL: China is adding an astonishing amount
of wind and solar to its grid every year.
RN: It's cheaper to build
a new solar or wind farm
than it is to put fuel
into a natural gas plant or a coal plant.
TB: Our job has to be to make sure
that politicians know that they're going
to have the support that they need
for the hard policies.
LN: We need people to get on board
in a fight for climate justice.
And this means getting people on board
that have never spoken
to each other before
and that have always disagreed.
MB: Even at this conference,
you will meet people
and you expect them to have
very particular sort of, polar stance.
But when you actually
get into a conversation,
you see the openings.
CA: I love listening to people
with different points of view.
Dialogue is absolutely essential
and so generative.
But once we leave the safe space
of this conversation,
we go back out into a world
that is rife with power dynamics
and institutionalized,
structural inequities.
And we have to just acknowledge that fact.
RN: So I think it's not
a bad thing to listen
and then apply your own judgment
to what you've heard.
And is it self-serving or not,
and what nuggets of truth
or what pieces of data are there?
MB: What we don't want to lose
is that ultimately there are people
at the heart of systems.
And systems change will sometimes fail
just because two folks
cannot get along with each other.
Jade Begay: I think we overlook
relationship building
as kind of cheesy or corny,
but ask any person
who’s built change over time,
and it happens through relationships.
MR: I was very affected,
as were the other women leaders,
when Jade said,
"In our tribe in New Mexico, we say,
'What if our best times
are still ahead of us?'"
Our best times are still ahead of us.
But so are our worst times.
We have that choice.
And of course, we have
to choose our best times
and we have to know how difficult it is.
And yet, Nelson Mandela famously said
"it always seems impossible
until it is done."
And I love that phrase.